Voilà le problème !
C'est normal qu'on s'embrouilleavec toi, tu triches !
J'ai pas trouvé le temps, à vous !
Pourquoi tu réponds pas ?!
Reprendsla cigarette !
C'est bon ça va, ils ont gagné !
Bonjour à toutes, bonjour àtous.
Ici une une petite partie du casting de Pamela Rose, la série,
et noussommes ensemble pour jouer au jeu du Devine Qui ?
Jingle !
Messieurs, pile ou face ? Ou pas pile ?
Face !
Pile ou l'autre pile !
Et c'est pile, c'est qui commençons.
Comment tu sais quoi est pile et quoi est face ?
Quand tuauras mon âge, tu le sauras.
Ah bah tiens !
Bah non, dis pas : "Ah bah tiens" !
Bah si, ça va je peux dire "Ah bah tiens", ça donne aucun indice.
C'est bon !
Alors... premièrequestion c'est nous qui la posons.
Mais pour leur truc.
A-t-ilplus de 50 ans ?
Non.
T'as répondu trop vite, toi.
Ok très bien.
Comment tu sais ? C'est pas possible, tu le connais pas.
Bon bref.
Ah tu le connais pas...
Hop, hop, hop. Non. J'suis con, j'ai déconné.
Faut pas déconner.
On parle trop, on parle trop.
Mais du coup on peut rien éliminer, Olivier.
Tu as posé une question qui... On sait pas qui a quel âge.
Ah oui, tu as raison, tu as raison. À vous !
Attends ! Ben non.
J'ai pas trouvé le temps, à vous !
Vous avez cette réf ou pas ?
- Jean-Michel Avou.
- Jean-Michel Avou ! Je l'avais la réf, t'as vu ?
Est-ce que votre personnage joue dans le premier épisode ?
Ça, c'est une bonne question.
Non.
OK.
C'est une très bonne question !
- Alors attends, c'est pas compliqué. Il n'y est pas dansle premier ?
- Non.
Si, si, si, il est dans le premier. Il est dans le premier.
Est-ce que votre personnage travaille au FBI ?
- Non.
Non non non non non...
C'est oui ou non !
- C'est non.
- Non.
Il travaille pas au FBI ?
Non...
J'pense que c'est Sacha Sho.
Ça va, vous vous amusez, vous ?
- Il travaille au FBI hein ?
- Non, il travaille pas au FBI.
J'aime pas, j'sens que je vais perdre. J'aime pas, ça m'énerve.
J'ai envie de jeter le truc à la gueule...
Est-ce que votre personnage est blond ?
Non.
Ça va éliminerbeaucoup de gens là.
Tac tac tac tac tac...
- Il est pas blond hein ?
- Non.
- Non, il n'est pas blond.
- Il y a autant de blonds ?
Ah, m*rde, non ! Je me suis trompé.
Il a enlevé tous les bruns.
Non, je voulais dire : est-ce qu'il est brun ? Pardon !
Ça y est, trop tard.
Non, c'était brun.
C'est pour ça que tu perds, tu sais pas jouer !
Tu poses pas les bonnes questions !
Oh, j'ai merdé là. J'voulais dire brun !
Bah oui, on a compris.
Est- ce que votre personnage estaméricain ?
- Ça veut dire quoi ?
- D'origine américaine.
Ouais, ouais...
Ils sont tous américains, non ?
Ah non.
Non.
- Ah non parce qu'il y a les Augusto, et tout ça.
- Ah, mexicains.
C'est muy bien.
- Est-ce que votrepersonnage porte un chapeau ?
- Non, non.
Les bâtards.
Est-ce que votre personnage apparaît beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux ?
- Ça veut dire quoi ça ?
- Tu peux dire youtubeur.
- Ouais mais non, parce que regardes. Tu vois aussi.
- Ah oui, d'accord. Bah oui.
Est-ce que votre personnage est très présent sur les réseaux sociaux ?
Présent oui, oui.
Non jete jure, c'est pas une bonne question.
- Présent ?
- Présent.
- J'aurais posé autre chose.
- Présent ! Trop tardn vas-y. Présent !
Tout le monde est sur les réseaux sociaux, c'est idiot ton truc.
- Non mais j'ai dit : est-ce que votre personnage
est TRÈS présent.
- J'ai dit : présent sur les réseaux sociaux.
- Tu dois répondre sur "TRÈS présent".
- Non, présent.
- Il est présent, on sait pas, il y a pas de valeur de...
Il y a pasde valeur.
- Bah si.
Il est présent sur les réseaux sociaux,
c'est une réponse, monsieur !
Démerde-toi avec ça.
Tu vois, voilà le problème ! Reprend la cigarette !!
Est-ce que ton personnage est très présent sur les réseaux sociaux ?
T'as pas répondu.
- Ça veut dire que t'es obligé de donner le personnage !
- Ouais, on l'a votre personnage.
Vas-y.
Non, non réponds à laquestion !
Est-ce qu'il est très présent-
Il est présent sur les réseaux sociaux !
P'tain, pourquoitu réponds pas ?!
Moi je te le dis : il est présent.
On n'hésite pas à s'abonner, le pouce bleuen l'air !
C'était Sacha Sho, et gardez la pêche !
Allez, salut les potes-au-feu !
- Mais oui, il est présent,oui.
- Il est présent !
Je pourrais même te dire : "il n'est pas très présent",
je pourrais dire.
On dit ce qu'on veut.
Est-ce que votre personnage est en costume ?
Euh oui.
Costume... costume?
- Ça veut rien dire, ça.
- Oui, costume.
- Costume... costard ?
- Oui, un costard oui.
Mais ça fait beaucoup, ça.
Est-ce que votre personnage est un peureux ?
Grand peureux.
Moi j'veux un caramel machiato sans gluten, merde !
- On l'a.
- Peureux, il est peureux. Oui, il est peureux.
Ouais, il est peureux.
Ça j'enlève.
- Ah mais non, c'est lui je te dis.
- Ouais, ouais, je sais.
Allez une dernièretentative.
Est-ce que votre personnage a une barbe ?
- Non. Euh si, si. Bah si.
- Oui oui, il a une barbe.
- Non par contre, oh les bâtards !
[- Il faut attendre le prochain tour.]
Pourquoi faut attendre le prochain tour ?
- C'est dégueulasse.
- Vas-y on le fait ensemble.
- Bah on l'a.
- Ouais vas-y.
- Sacha Sho.
- Okay.
- Et nous on peut proposer ?
- Ouais.
- Adam ?
- Let's gooooo !
- Égalité, moi j'dis !
Ah non, on a gagné.
Moi, je l'avais il y a2 tours en vrai, mais c'est juste pour faire durer le jeu que j'ailaissé.
- Hein, c'est vrai ?
- C'est vrai qu'elle l'a dit
- Et je t'regardais toi en faisant hm, hm !
Ben ils ont gagné, c'est bon, ça va.
Ils ont gagné !
- On y va ?
- Allez !
Est-ce que votre personnage est
dans le premier épisode ?
Tu vas poser les mêmes questions ?
Attends. Tac, tac...
Attends.
Non, sûr et certain.
Mais si, c'est carrément l'entrée.
Mais non, c'est non. Donc, c'est non ?
Il y est pas, il est pas dans le premier épisode.
Ah, donc c'est ça.
Ça c'est des gens qui sont dans le premier ?
- Oui !
- C'est ça.
Tu veux dire dans Pamela Rose, la série ? Oui, oui.
Est-ce que votre personnage est brun ?
Euuuuh, oui.
Ahhhh, ça veut dire
qu'il a pas de cheveux.
Oui, il est brun.
- Brun, c'est oui ?
- Oui il est brun, maisbon...
- Sûr ?
- Oui, il est brun.
Dis pas, mais il est brun.
Est-ce que votre personnage a plus de 40ans ?
Euh oui.
Alors plus de 40 ans...
Attends, qu'est-ce que t'as baissé parce que j'ai peur.
Est-ce quevotre personnage porte une moustache ?
Oui.
Est-ce que votre personnage fait partie intégrante duFBI américain ?
Non, non.
Est-ce que votre personnage a des cheveux ?
Ou des poils ?
Oui, oui.
- Ou des poils, hein.
- Oui.
Est-ce que votre personnage a une barbe ?
Non.
- Vas-y.
- Ah il vous reste vraiment qu'un seul ?
Rita !
Non !
- Booouh, les nuls ! Trop nuls.
- C'était pas ça ?
T'as dû baisser un truc.
Du coup attends, si vous vous trompez,
normalement
on a genre 2 chances ou 3 questions
en plus normalement.
- Parce que là excusez-moi, c'est un carnage.
- On va pas y passer la journée non plus. Attends...
- C'est nul ! Vous êtes nuls !
- Qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé ?
- Trop nuls.
- On était trop sûrs de nous, merde.
- Sur quoi on a merdé ?
- Je pense c'est sur le 40 ans.
Alors, est-ce que...
Est-ce quevotre personnage est un humain ?
Oui.
Oui, c'est un humain, pourquoi ?
À nous ? On peut encore poserdes questions ?
- Ouais, vas-y.
- Tu mens ou pas ?
Ah bah non, je vais pas mentir.
Ah non, c'est un humain !
Alors là, comment on fait ?
On est perdus là.
Il n'a pas de barbe. Attendez, on peut rejouer ?
Il a plus de40 ans.
Normalement, on a une question en plus parce que-
Ohh tais-toi !
Ça c'est en Algérie, mais pas ici !
- C'est un vrai mauvais joueur. J'adore.
- C'est terrible.
La mauvaise foi.
Sans barbe, plus de 40 ans...
Moi je crois que je sais à quel moment
vousavez fait de la merde.
C'est une question à nous là ?
Bah oui, bah non, non !
On a répondu là.
On a posé quoi comme question ?
Est-ce que c'est un animal ?
- Non, non.
- Bah merde alors.
Est-ce que votre personnage a un chapeau, une casquette
ou un bonnet, un truc sur la tête ?
Oui sur la tête, oui.
On est morts.
- Pas du FBI, pas de barbe...
- Attends. Pas du FBI donc ça vire...
C'est moche un homme à terre, franchement.
DES hommes à terre.
C'est gênant en fait.
- Pourquoi tu refais tout ?
- Pour qu'on voit.
À nous. Il est dansle premier hein ?
Non, il est pas dans le premier justement.
Ah ouais, ouais.
Est-ce que votre personnage travaille au Vatican?
- Votre Sainteté.
- Jésus est revenu ?
Non, non.
J'aime bien parce que : est-ce que...
Alors, est-ce que votrepersonnage... Vas-y, à toi.
- Formule.
- Vas-y, ouais. Est-ce que...
- Formulation.
- Est-ce que votre personnage acollaboré de près
ou de loin avec le FBI ?
Non.
- Il a pas collaboré du tout avec le FBI ?
- Non.
- Si ?! Ah bon ?!
- Que ce soiten interrogatoire...
- Ah oui, oui !
- Par contre, si tu triches...
Oui bon, peut-être, oui.
Les vidéos, c'était qu'unemise en scène.
On discutait ensemble souvent.
On avait même un groupe Whatsapp tous les trois.
- Tu peux répondre parce que là, on a un gros tricheur.
- Oui il a collaboré, mais je pensais pas dans ce sens-là.
- Il est plus amené que moi...
- Il a jamais travaillé auFBI !
- Non, c'est pour ça que j'ai bien précisé.
- Mais il a collaboré avec le FBI.
Que ce soit en interrogatoire, qu'il donne
des informations pour aider le FBI,
que ce soit quelqu'un qui soit déguisé pour le FBI...
- Non, c'est pas lui, c'est pas lui, c'est sûr.
- Non, c'est pas lui.
Bah alors c'est pas lui... et c'est pas lui.
- Ah ouais, bien joué.
- C'est pas lui.
Est-ce que votre personnage est John ?
Non, non.
C'est pas possible...
Non...
- J'adore, ils sont trop nuls.
- "Ils sont tropnuls" ?!
Est-ce que votre personnage a quelque chose,
ou cache quelque chose ?
Hein ?
QUEEEAA ?!
Est-ce que...
Estado... Estada...
C'est une IA, ça ? C'est une IA, j'reconnais.
Dans sa poche ?
Nan, est-ce qu'il cache quelque chose?
Où ça, dans sa poche, chez lui... ?
- Non, un secret.
- Est-ce qu'il cache quelque chose à la police, principalement ?
Oui, oui bah oui, forcément.
- Là, t'es vache, qu'est-ce que t'es vache.
- Franchement, c'est horriblede jouer avec toi.
J'ai dit : "OUI, forcément".
C'est normal qu'on s'embrouille avec toi !
Tu triches !
Chuuuuut.
- Je veux partir.
- Il a quelque chose àcacher ?
T'as vu comme tu es mauvais joueuse, toi.
- Ben non, mais avec quelqu'un comme toi, c'est pas possible !
- J'ai répondu oui, oui il a quelque chose à cacher.
À vous, posez votre question.
Laisse tomber, on va les avoir.
Je sais comment on va faire.
Est-ce que personnage a les cheveux
longs ?
Euh non, non.
Non.
- Est-ce votre personnage...
- Nan, nan, wesh !
Ah bah, tu permets ouais, Yvick !
Chacun son tour, en fait.
- Est-ce que...
- On n'est pas au Canada.
Oh la la.
Est-ce que votre personnage... meurt dans la série ?
Je sais même pas.
Non. Non ? Non il meurtpas ?
Non, il meurt pas !
Il ne meurt pas ! J'ai répondu !
Il ne meurt pas, d'acc, OK d'accord. À vous !
Est-ce quevotre personnage... attends.
- Parce qu'on avait dit pas de barbe.
- Ouais.
Il a de la barbe ? Non, il n'a pas de barbe.
Est-ce que votre personnage...
Demande direct si c'est lui, non ?
Alors tant pis, on attaque.
À moins que ça soit ça.
Ah non, il est dans le premier épisode !
Ça peut pas être le même quenous quand même.
Est-ce que votre personnage...
Un cauchemar, c'est un cauchemar.
Est-ce que votre personnage... attends.
C'est un cauchemar !
- Si on devait décider des 3, comment tu ferais ?
- C'est un cauchemar !
Je dirais le premier.
- Celui-là ?
- Oui !
Est-ce que votre personnage est Mexicain ?
Oui.
Non, t'as pas le droit encore.
T'as pas le droit, c'estle tour d'après !
- Du coup, nous on fait quoi, on tente ou... ?
- C'est l'un des deux de toute façon.
Allez, on tente.
Est-ceque votre personnage est Lord Kimba ?
Motherf*cker !
Ouaaais, trop forts !!!
À nous !
Et vous, est-ce que c'était Augusto ?
Non !
Oh, p'tain !
Jusqu'au bout vous l'avez pas, bande de nuls !
- Mais il est pas dans le premier épisode ?
- Non. Il apparaît pas dans le premier, non.
Il apparaît dans le deuxième.
- C'est sûr ? Il est pas dans le premier épisode ?
- Nan nan, sûr sûr sûr.
Bien jooouué.
Bon voilà, merci, au revoir. Super !
Ça faitlongtemps que j'avais pas rigolé comme ça
en gagnant un jeu.
La question c'est : est-ce quetu joueras encore
maintenant avec... avec...
Avec qui ?! Donne mon nom, déjà !
- Oui oui, bien sûr.
- Le pire joueur !
- Tu seras pas dans la saison 2 !
- Je m'en fous, j'dis la vérité !
Lui il sera dans la saison 2 !
YEEEES !
Bon, merci en tout cas.
Oh la vache.
Voilà comment on décide les acteurs
de la saison 2.
La série, on la retrouve sur CANAL+.
Évidemment disponible sur myCANAL, tous lesépisodes en one-shot.
- Binge watch ! Binge watch !
- Ouaaaais, évidemment.
Et achetez mes pizzas !
Puis allez voir Ruy Blas, au Théâtre Marigny à 20h.
Maintenant, j'y vais. Bonsoir messieurs.
Bon appétit, messieurs !
Le dernier jeu de société qu'on a fait avecOlivier,
entendez bien ce que je vous dis,
c'était sur un bateau aux Grenadines, en croisière.
On étaitpartis tous les deux avec nos femmes. Tu te souviens ? Sur un bâteau.
- Ça fait bizarre de dire qu'on est partis tous les deux.
- Olivier venait d'arrêter defumer.
- On a joué à un jeu qui s'appelait comment ?
- Cranium.
- On s'est brouillés pendant, je saispas... Ça a duré 1 semaine.
- Une journée ! Une journée, arrête !
Il avait arrêté de fumer,
il était comme ça, il était nerveux.
Moi, je déteste jouer, ça m'énerve.
J'ai pas envie de perdre, enfait, voilà c'est tout.
Et moi, pareil.
- Et là, sur le bateau, embrouille, tu vois.
- Allez !
Lui à l'arrière, moi àl'avant.
Et les femmes au milieu qui disaient :
"Qu'est-ce qu'ils sont cons."